this video is brought to you by
brilliant problem solving based website
and app with a hands-on approach improve
your STEM skills while having a great
time learning as brilliant at org /ban
graphics more on them in a bit human
history is littered with people who
changed the world so need to have their
achievements erased from popular memory
a gay men like computing pioneer Alan
Turing women like mathematician Ada
Lovelace even pure oddballs like Nikola
Tesla were left out of the curriculum
for decades thankfully this is no longer
the case on the Internet everyone from
the Navajo code talkers to NASA's black
female number crunchers having their
stories told what if we told you that
there's still a name missing from their
ranks one that should be on everyone's
lips the name of a female mathematician
so influential her work may be second
only to that of Albert Einstein her name
was amin notre and her work changed
history born into a german jewish family
in the late 19th century notre grew up
in a world designed to reject people
like her barred from attending
university due to a gender she
nonetheless managed to attain a grasp of
mathematics so phenomenal that her work
created an entire discipline anonymous
in her lifetime ignored by posterity
this is the life of Emmie notre the most
important mathematician the world forgot
[Music]
when amino 2 was born on the 23rd of
March 1882 it was into a family that was
almost designed to produce geniuses her
father max noter was a highly respected
mathematician attached a lung in
university her mother came from the
wealthy Kauffman family of Cologne
although ne was the eldest brother Fritz
would become almost as famous a
mathematician as their father in short
this was a family of wealthy brain
boxers intimately connected to a very
prestigious university with such an
upbringing
how could notre not succeed yet this
outward advantage masked a less
privileged reality the notas they would
Jewish Max's ancestors have changed
their names to try and blend in with
German society
well Germany in the late 19th century
was much less anti-semitic than it would
become the first traces of poisonous
racism were already there although
notice Jewishness would turn her into a
target later in life it wasn't solely
what made her early as difficult
no that was notice bad luck to have been
born female we say bad luck not to rile
up our female viewers obviously but
because it really was a disadvantage
back then while as a very young girl
Notah was desperate to follow in her
father's footsteps into mathematics
society at the time was kind of like
girls don't do maths I noticed childhood
may not have been fulfilling but at
least she was happy at elementary school
her teachers noted that she was always
laughing
in fact happiness seems to have been
notice default setting throughout her
life she spent her childhood dancing to
made-up songs telling jokes and getting
highly excited about anything that
grabbed her fancy yet there were signs
of something deeper at work as she
entered her teens no.2 began spending
longer amounts of time lost in her own
heads like she was distracted by a voice
that only she could hear already it
seems she was spending more time
puzzling out reality than she was living
in it
the puzzles weren't for nice girls so no
to spends her day-to-day life training
to be a language teacher she did a
pretty good job too when she took for
teaching exam in 1900 she received the
second highest possible grade but Emily
Notah would never do even an hour of
paid
which teaching in her life in that same
year 1900 nota
seemed to decide well to hell with what
society wanted she applied to study
maths at a Langan university at the dawn
of the 20th century women were forbidden
from attending university classes in
Germany at least they were officially
forbidden unofficially professors were
given leeway over who they allowed to
sit in on their lectures this was
something of an advantage if for example
your dad just happened to be a respected
maths professor at the University that
you wanted to attend
not long after no.2 began sitting in on
Ilan's maths courses only one of two
women in the entire university for the
next two years she progressed so quickly
that when she sat an equivalent exam in
1903 she passed with flying colors had
she been male nota
would have doubtless now find herself
riding a rocket ship to the very heights
of academia but unfortunately her double
X chromosome disqualified her from doing
anything remotely fulfilling so instead
she went to göttingen University to sit
in on yet more classes however notice
winter stints in göttingen would turn
out to be a blessing in disguise while
there she studied under David Hilbert
and Felix Klein to have the most
distinguished mathematicians in Germany
neither of these three geniuses knew it
in 1903 but as they were just over a
decade away from a collaboration that
would change the world
[Music]
in spring 1904 the German government
suddenly dropped a bombshell from the
following semester onward women would be
allowed to enroll at the Empire's
universities for Notre this was like
spending your entire life standing on
the sidelines at a dance only to
suddenly be invited to join in although
admittedly in this metaphor dancing
involves a whole lot more algebra than
it usually would anyway
motor raced backed Langan lands on
October the 24th
she sat her entrance exam did she pass
well of course she did
that year 1904 Notah officially joins
one of the first mixed sex maths courses
in germany remarkably she doesn't seem
to have encountered any real resentments
while it likely existed in some form
most of her professors seemed to have
realized that she had a gift for the
subject three years after joining on
Friday the 13th of December 1907
Notah took the examination for a PhD she
passed so handily that she graduated
with the highest honors possible to
return to our earlier metaphor this
moment is noted dancing so spectacularly
that the entire Hall just stops and
watches Hart it also happens to be the
moment some assault janitor snaps the
lights back on and brings the whole
dream to an abrupt end
although notre had a PhD in math she
wasn't allowed to actually do anything
with it the law thought women should be
able to study but not lecture so noter
found herself in possession of a
brilliant mind and a stellar education
but absolutely nothing that she could do
with either of them still she did have a
couple of aces up her sleeve the first
was her mother's money thanks to her
family notre didn't have to get a job if
she wanted to she could devote her time
to the unpaid study of maths the second
ace was her father
by 1908 max notre was suffering more and
more from a disability brought on by
childhood polio he needed more time off
and a substitute who could cover him
when he couldn't attend class a
substitute just like any subbing for her
dad was an unpaid role but one which
allowed notre to remain in a Langan this
allowed her to keep on studying and to
keep on publishing papers the more she
worked the more notice she got in 1909
for example note was invited to go to
Salzburg to address the German math
matter
or society in 1911 she came to the
attention of Ernst Sigismund Fisher who
championed her work at along and sparked
her own interest in abstract maths by
1915 shortly after the outbreak of World
War one she was even overseeing two of
her father's PhD students advising them
on their doctoral thesis it's entirely
possible that she could have gone on
like that forever
kept right on working away in her long
and perhaps eventually making it on to
the salaried staff but 1915 was the year
that everything was gonna change both in
mathematics and in notas personal life
that was because 1915 was the year that
a former patent clerk Albert Einstein
blew up the entire scientific world
Einstein's theory of general relativity
was the most transformative event in
maths
since Newton decided to discover gravity
and save us all from pain lifetime of
weightlessness it turned almost
everything we knew right on its head and
lit a fire under the asses of every
maths department on the planet among
those with suddenly burning backsides
were Emily's old mentors David Hilbert
and Felix Klein that same year that you
identified what appeared to be a problem
in Einstein's theory one that seemed to
imply Einsteins work contradicted laws
on the conservation of energy but the
two of them alone weren't up to the task
of figuring out all the implications
what they needed was a fresh set of eyes
someone with expertise in invariant
theory no long after nota got a call
asking her to come back to göttingen and
she said yes now just before we get into
their move let me take a moment to tell
you about today's sponsor brilliant
which is a great fit for today's video
which of course is all about a
mathematician brilliant is a problem
solving based website and app with a
hands-on approach they've got over 60
interactive courses in maths science and
computer science now you've heard me
talk about brilliant before you might
even have a membership already in which
case why I'm sorry for wasting your time
brilliant teach you all about maths
science computer science but beyond that
they also help teach you problem-solving
skills which are practical even if you
don't plan on pursuing the sciences
learning how to break down complex
problems into their component parts is
just pretty critical in
any career path you choose brilliant are
always improving their platform and
recently they've launched a new course
on algorithm fundamentals it starts
simple with basic drag-and-drop
exercises and these were heavier
thinking like a computer scientist in no
time
they've also recently added more
interactive contents more of the puzzles
and the challenges that they're famous
for solar brilliance a great compliment
watching educational videos like this
one and it will really help you master
even complex and technical subjects so
if you want to support via graphics and
get unlimited access to all of
brilliance in depth maths and science
courses head on over to brilliance at or
forward slash buyer graphics and you'll
get 20% off their annual premium
subscription and let's go back to
today's video
when nota arrived in göttingen that year
it's fair to say the all-male faculty
weren't very pleased to see her
Hilbert's plan had originally been to
have nota appointed associate professor
to which some long forgotten stuffy
German dude replied what will our
soldiers think when they return to the
University and finds that they are
required to learn at the feet of a woman
to wit shall but resorted I do not see
that the sex of the candidate is an
argument against her after all we are a
university not a bathhouse us in the end
stuffy German dude carried the day and
Hilbert was forced to give no to the
unpaid position of guest lecturer at
which point notice showed everyone up by
solving the problem with Einsteins work
in about 15 minutes it turned out that
the problem wasn't actually a problem
Hilbert inclined had just been thinking
too small
using Einsteins work Noto was able to
prove that energy would indeed be
conserved across a sufficiently large
patch of space but it was what she
discovered alongside that that mate
notas named vas became the reason that
she deserves to be remembered
notice theorem would change the world
okay so we're gonna level with you here
in making this video write a ton of
articles trying to get our heads around
notice theorem so we could explain it to
you but it turns out it's really super
confusing and some people like us whose
primary job is history and who usually
responds the word algebra with a bit of
a screen it's not something we could
really manage so well lesson expertly
the talking in this case the New York
Times is Pulitzer Prize winning science
journalist Natalie Andrea goes like this
what the revolutionary theorem says in
cartoon essence is the following
wherever you find some sort of symmetry
in nature some predictability or
homogeneity of parts you'll find lurking
in the background a corresponding
conservation of momentum electric charge
energy or the like for example notice
theorem shows that asymmetry of time
like the fact that whether you throw a
ball in the air tomorrow or make the
same toss next week will have no effect
on the balls trajectory is directly
related to the conservation of energy go
mad throwing balls conservation of
energy solution to relativity great sure
okay
still even mathematical Luddites like us
can appreciate the historical
significance of note as work her theorem
will go on she hugely influenced a new
generation of scientists working in the
1950s and 1960s scientists who used her
work to predict the existence of new
particles one of those was the Higgs
boson the so-called god particle
discovered in 2012 takeaway amino
Turin's a theorem and the cutting edge
of physics today suddenly looks very
different unfortunately there was a
major barrier to most people actually
hearing about notice discovering during
World War one scientists working for the
Central Powers were forbidden from
sharing discoveries with rival nations
in case it led to some sort of military
breakthrough but one person did get to
hear about Emmys work after reading of
notice theorem Einstein wrote to Hilbert
in his letter he used a simple term to
describe the woman who'd come up with it
he called her a genius the next few
years have noticed life were odd to say
the least although she'd just made a
major breakthrough most of the world
didn't know about it on top of that the
University was still refusing to pay
errands with the German economy
shattered by war even money from her
parents wasn't enough to stop a sliding
into poverty but at least she was able
to continue working during this period
Homer managed to get around the
university's prohibition on solo female
lecturers by advertising notice classes
in his own name and then just forgetting
to show up it wasn't much missus allowed
notre to follow her passion then the end
of the war brought its own problems as
Germany plunged into chaos at the end of
1918 a chaos that only ended in August
1919 with the creation of the vomer
republic with the era of upheaval at an
end
notre and Hilbert fixed their sights on
a new target this was getting Notah a
real job at göttingen university by now
she had been able to publish a theorem
to a wider audience everyone knew that
she was a mathematician of staggering
talents but no the stuffy German dudes
on the University's Board that somehow
missed the whole discovering a
world-changing theorem bit and remained
intensely unclean on lady lecturers they
maintained this position all
way through 1921 even as noter published
a paper ideal theory in orion Brian now
seen as a major milestone in the advent
of modern algebra finally in 1922 the
university condescendingly awarded the
cleverest person in their midst with a
role as untenured associate maths
professor and allotted her a pitifully
small salary it was a victory of sort
but those stuffy German dudes were dicks
enough to make sure that it didn't feel
like one yet nota doesn't really seem to
have cared she was able to teach now she
was able to work on a passion she became
one of the most popular lecturers on
campus with a dedicated student League
forming around her known as the notre
boys and yes they were boys despite the
law change and notas presence there were
almost zero women studying maths at
göttingen and that reflects at the
deeper attitudes that were still
swirling around at the time in 1927 for
example Notah began a collaboration on
non-communicative algebra x' with two
male mathematicians but was only rarely
able to put her name on the papers still
the community itself championed her in
1928 for example she was invited to
address the International Congress of
mathematics at Bologna in 1927 she was
briefly given the job of visiting
professor at Moscow University
as time passed sines slowly began to
appear that things were indeed changing
in 1930 note omits the 24 year old Czech
math superstar ole Gutowski afterwards
she told her friends how pleased she was
the women were finally being accepted in
maths yet while acceptance might have
been growing where notas gender was
concerns an even more violent wave of
oppression was about to come crashing
down on her Notah was a prominent Jewish
woman living in 1930s Germany and
unfortunately we all know what's coming
next the same years at Notre met Olga
Tomsky the vimar Republic held one of
its frequent elections but while every
previous election had returned messy but
expected results the election of
September 1930 returns an unpleasant
surprise from one of the smallest
parties in the Reichstag
the Nazis were catapulted into second
place netting nearly a fifth of the vote
the era of Vimal democracy was reaching
its end around the corner lurked a time
of unspeakable horror this coming
nightmare wasn't immediately apparent in
göttingen especially for the apolitical
nota oh sure a couple of the students
started turning up the lectures wearing
Nazi brown shirts but nota just laughed
it off
she knew these boys she knew they would
never harm her the next couple of years
were accompanied by the steady drumbeat
of jackboots and despair in October 1930
the SA undertook its first major
anti-jewish action destroying
storefronts in Berlin two years later
Vimal Germany again went to the polls
this time giving the Nazis the largest
majority of seats and over 37% of the
vote YES nota still didn't realize the
danger she was in the same year that the
Vimal republic teetered on the edge of
annihilation she was accepting awards
for her maths work and addressing
international congresses in Switzerland
but her ignorance it couldn't last on
January the 30th 1933 Hitler was made
Chancellor of Germany a momentous event
celebrated nationwide by torchlight SA
and SS parades through cities not three
months later on March the 24th the
Reichstag passed the Enabling Act
pending Hitler absolute power the very
next month Noto was fired from göttingen
for being Jewish it was almost like
someone had been waiting for an excuse
to get rid of her note it was given no
compensation for the loss of her job
denied a pension and told she would be
unable to teach again the mathematicians
response was impressively upbeat note I
wrote to her friends I must say though
that this thing is much less terrible
for me than it is for many others at
least I have a small inheritance
I was never entitled to a pension anyway
which allows me to sit back for a while
and see and that's exactly what she did
through the summer of 1933 noter
continued to teach in private opening up
the front room of her home to any
students who wanted to learn maths she
even allowed her brown shirt students to
attends these informal classes ignoring
the fact that these boys had likely
marched through the city chanting Nazi
slogans just a few months earlier as a
friends have notice later noted she
never doubted the brown shirt student's
integrity this was about maths politics
could be damned thankfully no no
got to experience the true faces of a
Nazi students that fall worried about
notice increasingly precarious position
Albert Einstein arranged for her a job
lecturing Bryn Mawr College in
Pennsylvania remarkably she turned him
down if she was going to emigrate she
wanted to go to England
steeped Oxford not some American College
but it soon became apparent that she
didn't have a choice
across 1933 the Nazis passed a raft of
anti-semitic laws excluding Jews from
any professions and subordinating old
Jewish intellectual output to girl's
himself although physical violence
against Jews wouldn't become state
policy until 1935 it was clear now even
to the optimistic noter which way the
wind was blowing that october noter
boarded a boat bound for the USA not
long after she began a visiting
professorship at Bryn Moore with
remarkable luck
Notah had just escaped the clutches of
one of the most destructive racist
regimes of all time although she would
return to Germany once more she would
never again be victimized by Nazi
policies unfortunately her escape would
only turn out to be a reprieve nobody
knew it yet but the 51 year old noter
was only 18 months away from the end of
her life
[Music]
when death finally came vanilla it was
with a suddenness that was painfully
unfair across 19:34 no turrets settled
into a new life in America should begun
additional lectures at Princeton and
felt a small but devoted following at
both universities in fact it was in
America that she probably felt the most
accepted that she ever had in her life
no one in the States seemed to care that
she was a woman who wanted to teach
maths no one seemed to care that she was
Jewish
finally after half a century no tour had
found somewhere that seemed to accept
her for who she was somewhere she could
live out the rest of her life without
trouble
she even felt comfortable enough to take
a trip back to Germany that year while
riding on the Hamburg metro with her
brother she is struck up an excited
conversation about idea theory
mathematical concepts that in German
uses the term Fuehrer her brother's wife
would later remark that notice seemed
completely oblivious to how close she
came to being arrested for that
discussion as 1935 dawned Notah was
ensconced in Pennsylvania working on her
theories and seemingly enjoying a new
lease of life and then she got the news
on April the 8th doctors discovered
Notah had an ovarian cyst they
recommended her for surgery and on April
the 10th she went on to the knife as
they operated the doctors made a
gruesome discovery
notice insides were riddled with tumors
the great mathematician was dying the
death Wooden's of the decency to wait
another couple of months four days after
her surgery on April 14 1935 noter
developed a sudden and extreme fever an
infection had developed the doctors
rushed to save her but they were too
late Emily anotr died that same
afternoon at the time she passed away
she had only just turned 53 today her
name is all but forgotten outside of
maths and science circles even some who
know her theorem know nothing about her
they may even assumed that the note it's
named after was male and this is a
tragedy because her work changed the
world a whole lot of modern theoretical
physics is underpinned by her ideas and
her contributions to abstract algebra
were so huge that we've seen people
claim she basically invented the
discipline the weirdest part of all of
this is that people knew house
she was after noted I'd Albert Einstein
wrote in the New York Times in the
judgment of the most competent living
mathematicians Fraulein Notah was the
most significant creative mathematical
genius thus far produced since the
higher education of women began yeah
while Einstein remains a household name
while Kepler cancer and John Nash all
trigger hints of recognition notas name
has slipped into the fog
the most significant thinker that the
world somehow forgot but we shouldn't be
too sad for nota well she certainly
deserves more recognition it can't be
denied that her work lives on
influencing millions of thinkers helping
us to understand the universe she may
have slipped into obscurity today but
when the final Sun total of the human
race is added Tarpons the achievements
of all the billions and billions who
have ever lived are weighed it's
comforting to know that any nota will be
up there at the very top still smiling
away the mathematician who changed the
world so I really hope you found that
video interesting if you did please do
hit that thumbs up button below don't
forget to subscribe also check out our
fantastic sponsor who make videos like
this possible that's brilliance their
link to below
and thank you for watching